if you Toto skills gonna be coming up
first here down the hall of hype as we'd
like to call it a Vegas from there he is
the lone mitsurugi not exactly in the
world but damn this is placing to make
it look like he's the one mixer you're
right you know time and time again
incredible Claire's a fantastic person
always finally look at that dazzling
smile guy yeah yeah you you you would be
genuinely hard-pressed to see someone
smiling as much easy you've crashed the
white strips okay but yeah on the other
side however we're going to have the
evolution champion himself all the way
out from Japan you Toto coming down the
hall of life there he you know one of
the things he was talking about is he
didn't specifically trained for for this
event like in any different way he was
like I trained you know the normal way
and I just want to bring the same stuff
that I did previously here we are
cheered for him loud and proud of these
trips across stage to making that
massive flight all the way to get here
my god
oh man and look skill is so excited to
fight him so if this wholesome caliber
like personality so first we're gonna
hit some words from the tall talk here
check it out stop telling this at all
I know it's endure energy promote us
again indominus your party skills on to
Tyson
[Music]
and there you have it that's a little
you Toto he'd like I said he didn't
really plan to do anything different he
said he wanted to bring the same old
stuff but in this matchup in particular
for those of you who remember quite
possibly the best set that Soul Calibur
six has had thus far the winners finals
of evolution was these two skill versus
you toto and one of the things that they
both said about each other is that
they're specifically looking to fight
each other they they're looking forward
the most to look to fighting each other
all right so it's gonna get their whole
gift wrapped up in a package them games
you'll already get your dream here we
are
oh my god I have no doubts that this
will give us kind of the same energy
that we saw in the end that set because
you know it's skill has had skill set
when he played you Toto despite the fact
that he lost that scent um that was some
of the best hablar here played right so
he had to have looked at that he had to
have taken as much information from that
as possible and just learned so much
obviously your Toto you know being the
current best in the world just just by
the results obviously
obviously you know we all know that he
he can work old boy can learn but he
doesn't just have a Volvo he says that
he has many tournament viable characters
oh and not just as well that we saw in
Southeast Asia majors right he
specifically talked about how he he felt
that ball though he couldn't win if the
tide of battle changed away from his
favor with just father that he would
need to figure out a way to to play
another character let me tell you about
our Lord and Savior over here let me
tell you about skill okay
you've got that skill on luck okay my
guy out here with these godlike CII's he
catches you back stepping he catches you
breathing too much get seen this man is
crazy and I'm so excited to see this
match Mike
especially when it comes to meet or
those play style too right see this
match is just it's like a dream match
this is something that like if you had a
wish list of games you wanted to watch
this this would be one of them here we
go heading into Game one got skilled
bruises you Toto yeah ever since that
Evo set we wanted to see this run back
and I mean we're finally getting it here
you just so happens to be round one but
hey that's it's it's not like any other
match was I was gonna be any worse are
already blocking the low great job I
feel but you know what you Toto chipping
away yeah so specifically that low in
general is actually negative twenty it
so I'm blocking okay yeah so he's
already playing - whipping on it she's
trying to continue the pressure right he
doesn't want to allow you Toto to be
able to get buttons and Sur stands
transition and that's exactly it right
so he got the button in the stance
transition and then Scott was like no no
no we gotta stop this now right so he to
aid he was able to take the round before
it there was any chance of you total
running a mix-up gotten stance right now
and she I just whipped
try to flush it twice but not today okay
remember you are back turn so the friend
aid was a little bit better for curve
although in that situation
all right
Oh gives a show the baby let's go so
what you're doing right there when you
get an implied that low despite the fact
that your back turned when your negative
two is you're trying to represent that
no player cannot do a big right also can
still do something fast enough to stop
you if he so chooses but oh that's
actually I told you man I feel he
catches you breathing wrong you're gonna
get seen just like that Hill taking two
rounds up yeah that's one of the best
fights five playing an icy character on
the three you know right now a
punishable on block but man I mean if
you have the instincts just like skill
has shown time and time again through
many a tournament getting the launcher
here though as you're starting to fight
back here comes the set up I won't like
him a little bit spook so we got two
meters to work but still got nothing in
the butter jar yeah I mean but it's got
two rounds so it's like he can take a
few risks and do exactly that a lot of
loads coming out from skill actually and
you've got the life leave now no meter
coming out from Utah no just yet it's
I'm pretty surprised to be honest you
okay there it is
negative two and just got mixed up by
himself
yo-you totally not just old charger any
yeah but the thing is he has an AI 12c
II when he's back burn but unfortunately
it was just not fast enough for the
first game is gonna go to the skill I
guess when he's back to seeing increases
in brain aura will decreases in frames I
guess increase the frame advantage yeah
welcome advantage is on black ice or hit
right so it's it's it's decreasing
frames you know it becomes a faster see
on blocks so that's why he was kind of
just sitting there pretending the whip
buttons in the car cancelling it's cuz
he wanted the force skill to be able to
press a button he did exactly that it's
just he reacted just a hair too late
unlike skill earlier yeah skill first
game right now putting that pressure
back on I it has been very rare for you
to be able to get any sort of offense
started the only sort of offense that
he's gotten so far has been to lows I
mean there's only one right now boy oh
my god he's still hanging on you toto
you know he doesn't need to push the
advantage though is the thing is because
yeah he has enough of a life lead as
long as he plays like he's been uh you
know just just kind of waiting for you
told her to hang himself he's not
already up in space I I think it's fine
so the thing is that you talk to really
need to find a way around this this
offensive skill it just seems so
difficult right now for him he hasn't
been able to get anything started
outside of a few looks you get the
launcher here and there but it's just it
hasn't been enough okay he got the wall
splat okay here's the mix-up though what
is it gonna be plus brains and then he
challenges to disrespect right there
from skills it's important to represent
it's up against the wall and this is
yeah oh wow Oh step right back from you
it's also able to punish and now getting
armed aboard
signs of life from Utah so he's waking
up trying to figure out what's going on
in skills brain
okay want to talk right there
unfortunately he gets hit by the second
oh we've all hit right back at you yeah
that's the big thing as well yeah I have
none
all right we're the coolest soldiers we
gave did the loot property there gi
oh my goodness look at the damage from
just a couple of hits right there from
the defense'll chart okay a lot of meter
again for you tosser and remember he's
in back to it right now
he was yeah we took no straight we take
those you can look for to activate see
II all you want but the thing is the
skilled will get up in your face and
he's like I can't race yeah it's looking
super hard for you toss it I'm not an
offense right now still is just up in
his ass Oh train here mix up and a
little lid oh that's gonna have a chance
to mix up now you know everybody - here
we go
you total pretty with the blender oh wow
nice block right there in the mid from
skill he's gonna could activate the sole
charge right now this is the first like
defensive use of the bar we've seen so
far he's in fact hurt again and he gets
hit by the house leaping skill is gonna
do it putting you Toto into the loser's
bracket and I gotta say it wasn't attic
kill yeah I mean he was chipping away at
him so so well he got up in his face he
just he basically just poked at and
poked at and poked at him and anytime
that you told to wanted to press a
button
not even like anything big right he just
wanted to press like a 5a or something
like that he would just get counter hit
out of it it was kind of reminiscent of
the way that link horse was playing in
the first match that he had fly it was
just the whole time it was it was wild
you know what we saw things at skill
we see time and time again in a lot of
these tournaments but during this match
with you Toto the respect they had it
towards each other the entire time was
like constantly step guarding and just
checking each other and not even not
even pressing a button just going back
and forth movement that shows the level
of respect they had for each other
because one they know about the
positioning it was it was the very fast
the critical critical edges yes
on top of that too when it came to the
meter use right we didn't see him
busting like we didn't see skill busting
a like a crazy mounted like the meter
moves in general but instead keeping
that extra set of skills in mind
so instead like hang hey I'm wearing my
tool belt now care about these new tools
but I'm still holding a wrench yeah